after a ton of hype about captain
Marvel's powers and her potential to
take down Thanos why did the
interstellar heroine have such a tiny
role in avengers endgame the film's
writers have revealed the real reason
Avengers infinity war teased the arrival
of Carol Danvers and a buzz worthy
post-credit scene and Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige said she would be
the most powerful character the Marvel
Cinematic Universe had ever seen
audiences were convinced she would be
the hero to finally bring Thanos to his
knees but then she didn't the film's Co
screenwriters Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely addressed exactly why in
a recent deep-dive interview with the
New York Times it turns out Captain
Marvel actress brie Larson filmed her
sequences for Avengers and gain well
before she shot her own solo movie and
apparently before it even had a
completed script which means that if you
go by the shooting schedules Avengers
end game is technically Carol Danvers
his first appearance in the MCU imagine
that having to guess we're definitely
weird it would be difficult to write an
arc for Captain Marvel an endgame when
her own origin story hadn't been pinned
down yet what kind of person is Carol
what drives her and what happens if her
motivations between movies somehow
contradict each other without the
foundation of a solo story in place the
end game team apparently decided to
dodge the problem entirely by not
including much of Captain Marvel in
their movie of course none of those
concerns got in the way of black panther
being a pretty major player and Captain
America's Civil War but things were a
little bit different with that film
while the events of Civil War directly
set up the story of Black Panther
endgame is kind of the other way around
picking up with a modern-day Carol while
her story is already in progress McFeely
explained we shot brie Larson before she
shot her movie she's sane lines for a
character 20 years after her origin
story which no one's written yet it's
just nuts we filmed the end game before
Captain Marvel we didn't have a script
yet really for Captain Marvel how does
that work how do you get into character
we figure it out McFeely also stated
that the goal of avengers endgame wasn't
to bring this hotshot new hero into the
mix and have her save the day
jerk she came to Tony Stark's rescue at
the top of the movie and she also
swooped in to aid the Avengers at a
critical moment in the final
battle using her signature move up body
slamming spaceships until they explode
but beyond that Dragon Ball level
spectacle captain marvel just wasn't a
major player in the defeat of Thanos
instead the writer smartly made the
choice to let the Avengers that we've
come to know for years take the
spotlight and in McFeely's eyes that's
the way it was meant to be he said
certainly Captain Marvel is an end game
a little less than you would have
thought but that's not the story we're
trying to tell it's the original
Avengers dealing with loss and coming to
a conclusion and she's the new fresh
blood Marcus added that Captain Marvel
also had responsibilities elsewhere in
the universe so of course she wouldn't
be tied up with the Avengers big time
heist mission help out where she can
definitely abandon her other commitments
no way as McFeely noted she's been in
space nearly half her life she has
obligations where the hell have you been
all this time there are a lot of other
planets in the universe and
unfortunately they didn't have you guys
so the weird thing is with the Captain
Marvel movie mostly focusing on Carol
becoming a hero on earth audiences
really have no idea what Carol's
interstellar obligations look like even
weirder is that the writers of endgame
didn't know much either McFeely and
Marcus's comments are fairly revealing
when it comes to the reality of
moviemaking at Marvel the studio maps
out its film slate years in advance and
uses each movie as an opportunity to
tease the next so far it's worked
exceedingly well but there's also a
slight drawback to this style of
production in that some films can end up
feeling a little hamstrung by having to
serve the needs of a broader narrative
what dialect wakka nada whoa whoa whoa
conda MCU filmmakers often have to work
their movies into the larger series in
ways that sometimes come off as a little
tacked on or at least hard to weave into
a story this appears to be sort of what
happened with Captain Marvel her solo
film and endgame now the Captain Marvel
has come and gone
fans can almost certainly look forward
to seeing a lot more of her in future
films Kevin Feige even teased the second
solo movie when he told screen rants the
making of a first film is in some ways a
brainstorm on the future and on what can
be so what it will be again is not clear
but what it could be is pretty amazing
it's also been confirmed that the first
few years of Marvel's post endgame plan
will be officially
out in summer 2019 meaning it won't be
long before we find out what the future
is for Captain Marvel and how big a part
she could play in the next phase of the
MCU check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite Marvel characters
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]